First a Spanish colony and then an American
one, Puerto Rico, a small island in the Caribbean,
defines itself as a free state associated
with the United States.
An associated state whose citizens have American
citizenship but, unless they move to another
state, cannot vote in the presidential elections
and, even though they have a representative
in Congress, he also lacks a vote.
All their major issues, be it political, economic
or military lie under the federal jurisdiction
of the United States.
Lately, there’s been much talk about this
territory, not only because in September 2017
they suffered the harsh impact of Hurricane
Maria, but also because a few months before,
in May of that same year, Puerto Rico declared
itself bankrupt.
After more than 10 years of economic crisis,
Puerto Rico’s public accounts could no longer
keep going.
Because the island’s public debt surpasses
70 billion dollars and another 50 billion
in future payment commitments, such as pensions.
Dear viewer, we’re talking about figures
that are huge for an island that barely has
more than 3 million inhabitants.
Due to this, in recent years Puerto Rico has
begun to be known as the Greece of the Caribbean.
Because, dear viewers, Puerto Rico is, simply
and plainly, insolvent.
But...
How did they get to this point?
Listen up.
Lately, there is a lot of discussion going
on, on how to solve Puerto Rico’s serious
crisis, and on how to stop the exodus the
island is suffering, which we saw here in
a past video.
But first... to address this issue, I think
we need to answer a question...
What on earth happened?
What caused Puerto Rico to be so insolvent,
what lead it to be a broke island?
Well, of course the great culprit has been,
without a doubt, the Puerto Rican government
itself.
A government that has been spending uncontrollably
for decades, has had many suspicions of corruption,
and an absolute disdain for production.
But, beyond Puerto Rico’s government...
Washington also holds a large responsibility
in this whole mess.
My friends, Washington's responsibility is
so great, that it wouldn’t be unreasonable
to say that the federal government has been
the great driver of Puerto Rico’s bankruptcy.
You heard that right.
The United States has “bombarded” Puerto
Rico with 5 policies whose results were devastating.
Five policies concerning trade, regulations,
salaries and welfare.
Don’t believe me?
Keep listening.
(TAX-FREE DEBT)
With the supposed intention of helping the
Puerto Rican economy and aiding its government
to access the capital markets, at the dawn
of the Jones-Shafroth Act, Washington created
a triple municipal, state and federal exemption
on Puerto Rico’s debt’s interests.
Thus, if any US citizen purchased Puerto Rico’s
public debt, he or she was exempt from paying
taxes on the interest received.
In other words, if an American bought debt
from a company, they had to pay taxes on the
returns obtained, but if he or she invested
in the debt of Puerto Rico’s politicians,
he or she didn’t have to pay anything at
all.
So... you can imagine that with such attractive
conditions, people would be queueing to lend
money to the island’s government.
Easy money that local politicians didn’t
take long to spend, aimed at a single thing:
buying, I mean, winning votes.
What better scenario could we concoct for
irresponsible politicians?
(TAX ENGINEERING)
Against all logic, while the federal government
encouraged the island to get deeply indebted,
it also made things harder for the private
economy.
You heard that right.
In 2006, Congress abolished the so-called
section 936 of the tax code, a section that
provided significant benefits for the companies
that invested in the island.
Let's not forget, my friends, that Puerto
Rico is the poorest territory in the United
States.
Well, the fact is that this incentive model
was very, very successful.
For years it helped Puerto Rico grow a lot,
even leading it to become an incipient manufacturing
and pharmaceutical power.
However, once the incentives were over, in
2006, two years before the great international
financial crisis, Puerto Rico began its fall
into the abyss.
Overnight the companies’ conditions changed
drastically...
forcing investments in the island to sink.
Legal security?
Ha!
But that’s not all, not at all.
(THE MERCHANT MARINE LAW)
This may be the most controversial point of
all... and at the same time the most absurd
law.
The Jones Act, which was passed in 1920 and
is still in force, forbids foreign-flagged
vessels to transport goods between two United
States ports.
Thus, a ship loaded with containers and coming
from China cannot stop in Puerto Rico, because
it has to continue to the mainland.
There the containers destined for Puerto Rico
are unloaded to then be loaded again on another
ship, this time one with a US flag and crew,
which is obviously much more expensive.
The result?
Puerto Rico has the most expensive shipping
costs of all Caribbean countries, something
that not only hinders trade but also makes
exports more expensive and reduces the every
Puerto Rican’s purchasing power.
In fact, to get an idea of this law’s implications,
we should mention that even though Puerto
Rico has an average income, which is approximately
half that of Mississippi, and is the poorest
state in the United States, its cost of living
surpasses the state average.
It’s crazy!
(MINIMUM WAGE AND WELFARE POLICY)
And if that weren’t enough…
there's more.
The average salary in Puerto Rico is the same
as the federal minimum wage, that is, $ 7.25
per hour worked.
The thing is that, as we’ve seen, both the
development level and average income in Puerto
Rico are much lower than those of the other
states of the United States, leading this
policy’s distorting effect to be... enormous.
See, the federal minimum wage in New York
or Illinois may affect a few people... but
in Puerto Rico... it’s different…
the federal minimum wage is equivalent to
77% of the average salary in Puerto Rico,
that is, the average salary of every profession
and job on the island.
This has led to only one in three people of
working age do so.
And, by the way, if this number is already
abnormally low, over a quarter of all people
with jobs work for the government.
Which means…
my friends… that less than 25% of the island's
population works in the productive economy.
On the other hand, the federal regulation
also implies an abnormally high level of social
benefits for Puerto Rico’s parameters.
In fact, studies show that for many families,
it is more convenient to receive social aid
than to work... because they income they’ll
receive is substantially higher.
Well folks, the result of these 5 federal
policies has been a huge crisis, a crisis
that has lasted more than 10 years, which
has caused – or has at least fuelled – the
island’s bankruptcy and has generated a
gigantic exodus of people who leave to the
continent, especially, of course the youngest.
As we saw here in a past video, only in the
last 10 years, 500,000, 500,000 Puerto Ricans
have packed their bags and moved to the continent.
That is 1 out of every 7 people.
There’s a lot of talk about how to solve
the island’s problems… but the question
is... is Puerto Rico’s current connection
with the United States compatible with any
of these solutions?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And as always, thanks for watching!